a uh white lady is very very upset
at other white ladies and she's very
upset at other white ladies because she
and her fellow white ladies
have committed a truly evil and
atrocious act
they have given birth to white men
buckland i'm going to get brutally
honest
the hand that rocks the cradle rules the
world
who created these monsters
we did
we birthed them
we nursed them
we read their little nursery rhymes and
sing the little songs
we taught them in their preschools in
their kindergartens and their first and
third grades
white women
craft their own gilded cage
and we do it
by raising little misogynistic
patriarchal tyrants
we raise the little boys
who grow up
to be the donald trumps
the mitch mcconnells
the greg locks of this world
white women raised them
now i hear you on the last sentence
when these little tyrants
grow up and abuse us and we speak out
about it yeah we're gonna be
institutionalized
yeah she's saying yeah they're gonna
call us crazy huh why would they ever
think we're crazy
we just hate ourselves and our kids
and she's got those eyes you can tell by
the eyes the eyes are usually a giveaway
this is the logical conclusion though
of the illogical i guess conclusion of
what the left is pushing
which is
a mother
despising her own
child
the politics of resentment
which starts out as just being about
everyone else i'm really good and
everyone else is really bad that
politics of resentment is going to come
back like a snake eating its own tail
and it's going to come back on a kind of
personal resentment she hates herself
because she's a white woman
she even hates her own child
ties right into the politics of abortion
why does the left
not merely tolerate or encourage
abortion to some moderate degree why
does the left make a sacrament out of
abortion why is abortion the sacred
fundamental right according to the left
it's it's at the very heart of this
politics of resentment mother teresa
made this point 30 years ago in a speech
at the united nations she said abor i'm
paraphrasing slightly
she said abortion is the greatest evil
in the world
and the reason is if a mother can kill
her own child
there is no limit to the evil and
depravity that will go on if a mother
can kill her own child and this video of
this lady is we are
the we should hate ourselves because we
have committed the great evil action of
giving birth and creating life so we
obviously need to hate our own children
that is the level
of animus
that you see on on the left you also see
this is the level of animus against
white men
the only group in america that you can
legally discriminate against
is white men
white people broadly to some extent
asian people because they get lumped in
as white people for some reason and men
kind of broadly but specifically at that
apex at the very tippy top of the
intersectional pyramid
it's
straight white men who know that they're
men and beyond legal discrimination in
college admissions and work it's the
only group that you're socially allowed
to constantly demean and insult
can't do that about black people can't
do it about hispanic people can't do it
about asian people can't do it about
women can't do it about homosexuals
can't do it about any other kind of
sexual identities other than
white men
straight white men who know that they're
men
that's the group that you can so vilify
that even their mothers are now
encouraged to vilify right now go to
ziprecruiter.com
knowles summer is upon us people are
traveling i've been traveling have you
ever thought that all the people that
make a great trip so great i'm thinking
of the hotel concierge i'm thinking of
the tour guide if you're going to some
wild destination i'm thinking of the
chef at the cool restaurant the
bartender you strike up a conversation
with you know outstanding talent is
crucial for a successful business if you
are hiring you can find talent for roles
such as these and more at zip recruiter
when you try it for free at zip
recruiter dot com slash knowles zip
recruiter uses powerful matching
technology to find and match the right
candidates up with your job you easily
review these recommended candidates you
invite your top choices to apply
ziprecruiter's got a complete suite of
tools that makes it easy to filter
review and rate your candidates four out
of five employers who post unzip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day that's why ziprecruiter is
the number one rated hiring site based
on g2 satisfaction ratings as of january
1st of this year travel to this easy to
remember web destination right now
ziprecruiter.com slash knowles that is
where you can try ziprecruiter for free
ziprecruiter.com k-n-w-l-e-s zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire
but before we go i've got to get to a
story about positive masculinity you
always hear about toxic masculinity
and i think this guy was a white guy too
i'm not totally sure he's definitely a
dude
a good guy with a gun saving a lot of
lives in indiana the reason you're not
going to hear about this story very much
is because it contradicts the libs
narrative
there was a mass shooter at a mall in
greenwood indiana
he fired into a civilian crowd
in uh at the food court
he killed three people he wounded two
people but before he could kill 20
people or 30 people a good guy with a
gun elisha dicken 22 years old
was there and he was carrying his gun
because of indiana's constitutional
carry law so only because of that
that great law that was passed in
indiana you had po culture downstream of
politics here the guy was carrying his
gun he pulls his gun out he shoots the
mass shooter and sadly the mass shooter
already killed three people he could
have killed ten times that
could have killed even more than that
you saw what happened in uvalde where
the cops didn't show up on time they did
show up and they didn't do anything
the good guy with a gun
absolutely vindicated you are not going
to hear
that story
one last little tiny final story there
are some republican senators right now
being led by senator joni ernst
who are proposing making june protect
life month it's the month of life
because that was the month that roe v
wade was overruled in the dobbs decision
i think this is a great idea
conservatives need to engage in the
culture we need
liturgical celebrations we need to
celebrate things all states always do
that it's kind of religious it's very
public and every culture has always had
these sorts of things public festivals
sacred days feast days right now we've
got a
sacred month quote unquote and it's
pride month in june and we have all sort
we have the mon black history month
women's month this month that month we
have traditional holidays the fourth of
july thanksgiving we have these kind of
sacred days we absolutely need one for
life you can't back away from the
culture you can't say oh well just keep
my values out of your life or this
that's that's not how politics works
it's not how it's ever worked and the
wind is at our sales here and people are
going to be supportive of this and
furthermore when we
when we act in a certain way when we
revere things when we venerate things
when we worship
together that affects the culture it
affects how we think and how we believe
there's this idea it's a catholic idea
lex orandi lex credendi lex vivendi the
way that we worship affects the way that
we believe it affects our actual views
of things and it affects the way that we
live the wind is at our sails dr fatchi
knows it
you all know it so let's push ahead and
let's get let's get the month of life
exalted in june so that maybe that will
move the way we believe and the way that
we live in the right direction i'm glad
you like that clip now i am very close
to a million subscribers i really want
to hit a million subscribers that's when
they're going to send me my big gold
play button and i'm going to feel like a
really really cool guy until they just
nuke my channel there's no way they're
going to let me get above a million
subscribers right there's no there's no
chance
that the powers that be well who cares i
don't mind i don't mind i want to
accelerate all the way there baby if you
don't mind subscribe ring the bell get
the notifications we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you